ANU SRIVASTAVA: Traditionally,
to write a document,
you'd start at the
beginning, right?
But if you're writing
a doc programmatically
with the Google Docs API, did
you know that it's actually
easier to start at the end?
Follow along and you'll see
why writing backwards makes
it easier to perform
batch requests for better
performance.
I'm Anu Srivastava,
and I'm going
to walk you through this
tip so you can easily
manage your start and end
indexes by making your insert
text requests in reverse.
Let's look at an example.
Don't worry.
For the video, we'll
start at the beginning.
I have a collection
of recipes that
need to be moved into Docs.
Moving information from a
database or some other storage
into a helpful format is
a pretty common issue.
The natural solution is to
read the recipe information
from my storage and then
write each piece into my doc.
Where it gets complicated
is organizing the updates.
Here, we have a lot
more than just text.
We have images, titles,
heading, lists, numbered lists.
It's a lot to consider.
So let's start with the
overview information.
Here we have a title, an image,
prep time, and then lastly,
yield info.
We'll use Insert Text to
write the title, and then
Insert Inline Image to add the
photo, and then Insert Text
again for the yield
and prep time.
First, let's look at
one of the requests.
Insert Text is just a note
of what text should go where.
So let's try it out,
starting from the beginning.
We write our heading, recipe,
and the title of the recipe.
So today, we're making
strawberry vanilla pancakes.
It's easy enough to add
the first word at index 1,
but then we need to keep track
of how long that text was so we
can insert that next piece.
So the word "recipe"
is six characters.
I can then insert
the title at index 7.
Easy enough, right?
But the titles will vary in
length from recipe to recipe,
so now we have to keep
track of each of those.
We're going to have to do
this again for every append.
Moving on actually
makes it worse.
So now I need to
know precisely how
long my text inserts
were so that I
know where to insert the photo.
And then I have to
remember that an image has
a length of 1 index, no
matter how large the image is.
So back to the documentation.
This is going to get
real tedious, real fast,
and I'm already worried
about off by one errors.
Imagine keeping track of indexes
for a really large application
with lots of things to insert
coming from different places.
So here is where
our trick comes in.
Since you have to set the
start index for every insert,
what if you started from
the end and always insert it
to the top of the document?
Our batch update insert
requests will look much cleaner.
I'd use a single
batch update and order
all of the updates in reverse.
So start at the bottom.
We'd start with Insert
Text for prep time
and yield info, then Insert
Inline Image for the recipe
photo, and then finally, Insert
Text for the title and heading.
It's so much simpler when
everything starts at 1.
One batch update request
contains all of my edits,
listed last to first.
Remember, a batch update
is simply a container
for my list of requests.
So now I'm starting at the end
and finishing with a title,
and no more tracking indexes.
Writing backwards, while
counter-intuitive, is simpler.
So you no longer need
to know or even care
about the length of each
one of your inserts.
Ready to try it
out for yourself?
Check out our
documentation, where
we have a document
structure guide that you
might find handy, and let
me know what you think.
Happy batching, everyone.
[MUSIC PLAYING]